uh all right so show us how it works uh
so the uh
i'm gonna log out of my account over
here and just log in to log into
australia i'm gonna log out of my
account over here uh and log into a
separate account every user gets their
own account because we're personalized
wait if i have three people in my family
does that mean i have to pay 150 bucks a
month
no absolutely not the the subscription
is for your households
got it is there a limit on how many
people so if i like have five people in
my dev house do we split the
50 bucks 10 bucks each we just ask that
you all live at the same address okay
fine so you can't rent this out to your
friends
oh i mean we're gonna be reasonable
probably not gonna stop you but
yeah we ask that people people pay for
it uh the
other thing is after you know after you
set your goals like liz said
the first step is to take a strength
assessment most people don't know how
much
weight to lift and so we have an
automated program it's a video that you
follow for 10 minutes that she that
finds out how strong you are god so
that's actually what liz is going to do
first
okay is show you how we assess your
strength and then and then she'll do her
first workout
just like luck so here we go
i have a feeling she's going to rip the
thing off the wall she looks pretty
strong
i like that yeah just lunge step
backward and plant your hand firmly on
the ground straightening out your back
leg
pretending to crush a coca-cola can with
that back heel from here
we're going elbow to instep exhale
rotate
up try to touch the sky still back leg
nice and straight you're going to return
both hands down to the ground
rock back toes to nose getting that nice
hamstring stretch
lunge step same exact thing on your
opposite leg
reaching back hand planted firmly on the
ground elbow to instep back legs
straight
reach up touch the sky inhale
exhale back down pulling your toes to
nose
and we're switching back to the opposite
leg
now world's greatest stretch is a very
dense
complicated stretch it's going to help
so i think this is a good place to fast
forward a little bit
okay so let's fast forward okay
so um
pullback so if you're doing an exercise
for the very first time
we teach you how to do the exercise so
he's going to walk us through walk liz
through the process of doing this
exercise
teaching her what correct form is right
you're going to need to pull the silver
lever located on the inside of the arm
and bring it up to parallel and then
push it one notch up
once the arms are set in position you're
going to adjust your bench
center it on your tonal and make sure
that when you reach up to grab those
handles and you sit down
that you're seated just in front of
where the handles are dangling from
once in position you're gonna pull down
and
back as if you're pinching a pencil
between your shoulder blades
i don't want you to lean forward and i
want you to touch your head to the
ceiling as you pull back and down
time for you to do three practice reps
total set are
low weight for these as you practice the
form and you can see the reps right
there on screen to follow along
go ahead and give it a try i also want
you to focus on
bringing your elbows back and down to
pinch those shoulder blades together
so this one is dynamically selecting the
weight i take it yeah this so this is
this is running a special mode that
tries to characterize the strength
velocity curve of her muscle
and then after that we take uh all of
these results
and use machine learning to recommend
all of the weights that she would need
for all the movements in our exercise so
she recommended 27 pounds
uh is the weight that was selected for
her for this particular movement if
she's going to do
10 repetitions of a of an overhead lat
pull down
27 pounds is her ideal weight